yeah our violent Jay is hanging out and
we welcome in yes Tyson hello hello
please come in have you met violent
before I have not met him not now that's
good
no sit down here before you would
remember
Sarah Sarah
yes yes welcome how are you man I miss
you guys it's good to see you you'll
call you know right well I'm I'm I'm I'm
I'm really glad that you're here because
you uh very famously at one point uh on
our show said
yeah I'll believe in aliens when you
bring a body into the Town Square and
you show the world well Neil deGrasse
Tyson yesterday
in Mexico a guy brought an alien body
into the Town Square do you believe in
aliens I love it that he did that so now
the next step is okay I like the way you
push your finger in with his fingers
right what you do next is what we did
when we brought moon rocks back from the
Apollo era you say all right
give a little piece to other scientists
around the world so they can analyze
this yes because one scientific result
is not what is true even though the
Press rushes to it I saw it okay the
press the Press rushes to it so now you
have to say can this be verified by
others and when you when you
verification then you can establish an
objective truth and I love me some
aliens and and by the way if that's
mummified there should be some soft
tissue there right there yep they're
right there anyway I love it that's it
if you love me some aliens two aliens
but what's a little odd he said he has
30 DNA overlapping with us which is not
very much right we have like 10 DNA with
a banana or something so 30 so alien
Mexican Congress they brought it into
Congress yeah and said here are some
alien bodies we found exactly three
things disappeared now they're gonna
vanish now yeah you never hear from them
again they'll be like uh yeah that's
what I'm saying you'll never hear them
on them again and then Neil deGrasse
Tyson they'll say yeah I don't know
anything about it so that's what
happened when he found the little one
remember the little one
the little alien this big no I don't
remember a little alien they found it in
was it Spain or something I think so
okay yeah yeah so did other people
analyze it or was it just kept in the
boxed it yeah it has like a a very some
anyway it ended up Vanishing so do you
remember the person who said they found
uh skin from Bigfoot do you remember
that and they had like Bigfoot flesh and
they had a big press conference yeah and
then they never showed up for the press
conference but the box was left there so
they analyzed the hair yeah and it was
like plastic hair it was like like a you
know Bigfoot wears a wig
oh no so here's what I'm saying
um so now get others to to verify but
here's my point
um
most life on Earth with which we have
much more DNA in common
than they are claiming for this alien
most life under does not have a face
I think worms don't have a face face is
a very vertebrate thing okay oak trees
don't have faces I've seen it wear them
with a face before
I've always giving him a hard time I
don't like him
if you have an alien from another planet
there's no reason for it to have any
resemblance to us at all at all this has
two arms the shoulders legs hips yeah a
a diaphragm a femur bones toes and what
has three fingers oh oh it's an alien
I'm saying oh my gosh is this the most
creative you can be if you're gonna hoax
the world that's right so if it's an
Intelligence being that wouldn't have to
resemble some sort of primate or
something well tell that to the whales
other oceans to swim in exotic Waters
that's right that's right that's right
yeah I'm just we're not some do we know
that we are the measure of what
intelligence how to intelligence can
manifest who we are in the universe sure
oh okay we're not the universe but here
on our galaxy sword Zach okay all right
so what I'm saying
right I love it I'm just surprised it
looks so human that's all if it's from
another planet what about okay the big
story too Avi Loeb uh and and those uh
pieces that came in of like 50 little
spherical maybe there was an
Interstellar interesting Interstellar uh
particles you said they were from
another part of the soul out of our
solar system yeah yeah what do you think
yeah they definitely are they're from
outside of our solar system well but
we've seen okay so so the back story
there if you didn't catch up on it yeah
is uh everything we've ever measured in
our galaxy so everything we've imagined
in our solar system orbiting the Sun was
born here and raised here
but we kept saying to ourselves the
Sun's gravity field extends much Beyond
this
so there could be some Interstellar
Interlopers just passing through so we
look at the orbits of comets and they're
all gravitationally bound to the sun
until a few years ago where we found the
first Interstellar object
which is Hawaiian for a first Scout and
then they repeat it first Scout first
Scout so it was like the very first
Scout it came riding through riding
through okay and so what was unusual
about it is it's trajectory through our
solar system did not match what Newton's
Laws would have held for it
it had a different Arc so you see well
what's doing that is someone commanding
this ship and doing what it having its
way with the with the trajectory or is
something else and typically comets have
outgassing and other sorts of things
that'll adjust the orbit on root so it
wasn't a terrifying Prospect but some
people ran with it
Avi lobe among them and said maybe this
was sent this is an Interstellar craft
that has its own navigational tactics
that was one final sentence in a much
larger paper analyzing it and the Press
went to that sentence and then he just
created an entire
off-ramp career
talking about aliens in space and so so
so back up
there was an asteroid impact in the
ocean that amateur astronomers viewed
and we got the angles on it he
calculated that it is on a trajectory
that would have come from outside our
solar system
and that was originally denied by the
military
but who cares we make a calculation
we're smarter than the military so I
don't this is not we're not going to say
oh really the Terry's right and my
physics calculate no so Avi uh published
a paper on this and then the military
recanted said we agree it was probably
Interstellar now we have Interstellar
material on Earth so he dragged the
ocean looking for whatever materials and
he found these ferals so that's why why
are they perfectly round though isn't
that weird that wouldn't that be made by
somebody they're perfectly round
extraterrestrial how big is it they're
Char they're tiny how the [__] did they
find that okay
what the [__] in the ocean the ocean I
just love it there's a clown face look
at me say how the [__] did they find it
that's just so that is so you know you
you guys made my day man I'm a fan of
this man you shot the hell on me when
you want
so how do you get round things okay so
watch if you take something that's
Molten
okay tell them that means liquid
you know I mean it's like yes I do okay
I clean it off my stomach
on this side of the table I start acting
the way he does and getting on your case
about it very hard it's very hurtful
it's very hurtful so if you take a a
molten anything and drop it through an
atmosphere the forces in the object that
will render its spherical so raindrops
are perfect spheres as they fall we
never draw them that way where they draw
them like there's a little oh but
they're spheres so that's how they make
that's how they make
ball bearings okay you drop metal
through the air and it cools as it comes
and it turns itself into a sphere I
wrote an essay called on being round
which talks about all the forces that
render things spherical I wrote the same
message
[Laughter]
to my website do you have something to
say you could say something too no I
wanna I wanna can we have a whole other
person here I need to ask you a question
because Violent J is here and it's very
important that we get to the bottom
because you're answering Jay's question
as well about how they find those things
in this question with you guys in the
same room yeah we can finally get to the
bottom of something yes because a few
years back
Violent J and his musical partner Shaggy
too dope they wrote a song called
miracles
and they asked a very scientific
question
magnets
how do they work they're Miracles
Miracles which I say I don't know how
they work so I'm gonna go with you on
this one okay I got I got a question for
you yeah
um you seen the guy flying in the basket
like it looks like 70s footage guy
flying around he's he's in like a basket
yeah no I missed that finally guy flying
in the basket Travis hold on hold on
okay I missed I missed the guy flying in
the basket you know what I'm talking
about I do not know okay we'll pull it
up okay I don't know if we're gonna be
able to find it because it's so dope but
I swear to God he's flying around in
like a craft he made he's standing in it
uh-huh right looks like he's flying in a
[__] big laundry hamper okay and he's
standing in it flying and uh you see him
playing around right he's gonna flying
around over feet a field right yeah then
he takes the [__] camera in the thing
and he flies around and shows you the
view you can see the shadow on the
ground everything you know what I mean
and uh footage been around forever right
okay cool okay so um he's done with
magnets you know if there are you mean
he told you he did it with magnets no I
I'm I'm assuming okay oh you're
wondering
it's done with magnets
the clarity yeah right and um if there
are aliens here right things I've read
and seen on TV which means it has to be
true
right yeah is you can bend [__]
gravity you know somehow and then create
some sort of Wormhole or something and
bypass time you know look at a black
hole isn't that the only thing that can
[__] with time in any way no spending
time is we are time is interfering with
us right now do you realize our our
clocks are ticking more slowly than the
clocks that are on GPS satellites
because they are farther away from
Earth's center of gravity than we are
the closer you are to a source of
gravity the slower your time takes and
they portray that in the movie
Interstellar when the guys went down to
the planet around the black hole they
were down there for 15 minutes they came
back up to the spaceship the guy had
been there for 20 years
time is always being touched
by your speed and by the strength of the
gravitational field you're in so then
why wouldn't they just rearrange it so
we can get the [__] off this gravity
plane and live to be 500. you know oh so
what you want to do is go to a higher no
you don't live you still live what you
think is your normal life relative to
other people they think you're living
more they probably don't make any
difference no no you don't you don't
feel this at all you'll see the future
that you wouldn't otherwise see
elsewhere but in your world everything's
going normal you don't even know it
right that's why it's called relativity
and that's why I'm believing God or
Creator okay because because a guy's
floating in a basket
for deeper reasons than that I'm telling
you right now I wish we could find that
[__] footage man because this guy you
got the basket Guy come on bro man it's
about magnets though they're using
magnets they're doing something with me
did he tell you he's using magnify with
no propulsion see I'm saying no blades
no here's what happens you know with
magnets the farther away you are from
the other magnet side of that equation
the weaker is the field so you can't
just keep going out into space
repelling whatever it might be thinking
he's only 10 feet off the ground but
he's zipping around you know but check
out his old footage from the 70s but
check it out um so why isn't there new
footage that shows it even better why is
it just developed by him because the
government came and said Sovereign
has no
equal confidence that other people have
that the government can hold a secret
look at how much we knew about President
Clinton's genitalia okay if there was a
state secret it would have been that but
there it is on TV it wouldn't have been
that why does anybody care to keep that
secret it means nothing I'm saying
there's a value no value to them so two
things have to be true the aliens or
whatever Secrets only are brought to the
government and no one else in the U.S
government and no one else in the world
and the government has to successfully
keep it a secret you know as an example
if they're stockpiling aliens in Mexico
New Mexico New Mexico
area 51.
no
the janitor would get a picture of it
Bible is our the Janet would lose his
job the next day but it'd be the most
famous richest janitor there ever was
I don't know
bro Joe to janitor up in there you know
what I'm saying my mom's been a janitor
her whole life they're just gonna let my
mom get up in there and start training
her the sneak sneakers saying around the
aliens dusting them off they would never
say something I'm sorry I just don't
know what to add to it well no but you
have questions about the unit we all
have questions about the YouTube I just
want to make my time too now you know
who this is right babe yeah I know who
he is yeah listen um I want to make my
point about what I said I believe in
holy Creator all right okay because no
matter what we can do
scientifically where we go in the
universe I don't believe anything we do
can never extend our time as a living
being what we already have you're living
twice as long as yeah in fact you really
mean three times longer than anyone 200
years ago and twice as long as anyone
150 years ago we have extended time and
guess what's doing it the methods and
tools of science there's a there's a
Comics guys
men sitting across from each other and
they're saying our water is clean our
air is clear our game is free range yet
we're still not living past 30.
this is I'm so yes science and and we're
on the tails on the heels of what might
be the aging gene or combination of
genes so it's not unrealistic to imagine
living to 150 within 100 years now so
now continue what you're saying okay
well let me ask you this then all right
you said uh what what the government
this and that why would all the
governments just be like oh we're all
going to keep this suitcase I don't have
that much confidence that the government
can keep a secret it's one of the most
incompetent entities in the world think
about it wow you know think about why is
it that the same people no no hear me
out why is it that the same people yeah
who don't like government uh
inefficiencies okay who don't want
government intervention because they
know they're going to mess it up all of
a sudden we see some fuzzy Tic Tac in a
Navy video and they're saying the
government is a masterminded entity that
is keeping all of this secret from us
all and they know all of a sudden the
government is some amazing organization
whereas at any other time it's being
criticized for how inefficient it is
can you really have that both ways well
you know it just feels like plus the
smartest people are not working for the
government what if there's levels to it
right what if there's an upper upper
that it's like the secret stop up here
like all that incompetency lower level
local government this person this person
this person but but even they keep
telling yourself that allows you that
allows you to continue to believe what
you want I believe it's Miracles see
what I have to deal with this this child
life connection on your side of the
table next time sure I would prefer okay
what question do you have about the
universe surely there's one about the
universe aliens God uh the edge of the
universe
we watch stuff about like aliens
sometimes yeah there's no end of Netflix
videos on Aliens we both like believe in
aliens okay
let me say that more precisely what
people have put forth as evidence I have
yet to find convincing ah so I maybe
they are aliens but I need better
evidence than what you're bringing forth
now we got some funky looking things in
Mexico great now let's Analyze That in
the labs and if we can analyze it if
they if they prevent that from happening
I don't know that's not how science
Works science you share you're excited I
didn't know that [__] happened yesterday
yeah it's pretty right yeah it's pretty
great and and they're sort of alien
leaning scientists so they have science
training so that which makes a little
more intriguing than just the tinfoil
Hat People
in Congress the Mexican Congress it
wasn't like it was just they did a video
at home don't use government
you're very interesting no I'm just
saying they are idiots yeah Mike we have
government hearings to decide whether
Earth is being invaded by aliens do you
think if we're being invaded by aliens
we would need government hearings to
establish that is true but whatever
really but what if there's a secret One
World Government that is like a whole
different deal what if I'm saying yeah
what if yeah so yeah that enables you to
continue to think whatever you want
thank you yes I appreciate that yes you
don't believe that there's five people
in the back here they don't say anything
Troy did you want to ask a question nope
Troy said nope they're getting in the
middle of that Mike did you have a
question for the for the good uh uh
Amazing by the way Neil deGrasse Tyson
who uh is promoting a brand new book to
infinity and beyond it just came out
yesterday available now now it's brand
new yesterday available now now wherever
books are sold and takes readers on an
awe-inspiring one-of-a-kind Cosmic
Adventure through the Galaxy and the
world's most celebrated astrophysicist
with the world's most soldiers thank you
all it does is say when you know
hundreds of years ago you're here on
Earth if you wanted to get to the moon
how would you think to do that did we
get to the moon yeah there are doubts
the government fantasy no here's what
they did that's right here's the story
right so the government said I'm glad
you're here this Moon thing is hard but
we have to go because the Russians
expect us to go so they went to
Hollywood right and they said we need to
we need to fake the moon landing Kubrick
so they go to they go to the and they so
they they analyze it and all the
producers said okay well if we fake it
we have to do this and we have to land
it and the lunar soil and the sky and
it's it's too complicated it'll be
simpler if we just fake it on location
why would tell me this then why was
Danny wearing that sweater serious joke
it was pretty good
listener on location that'll be easier
than making it why was Danny wearing
that sweater in The Shining if Kubrick
didn't do the moon landing you know what
I'm talking about 13 sweater come on I
do come on he's telling us something no
I have to watch The Shining again it's
pretty good yeah is it crazy film right
yeah yeah it is yeah yeah yeah yeah one
of the bags you know that's the movie
that first ever used a Steadicam camera
yeah when they're going down a corridor
yep uh and a quarter where you don't see
tracks in front of where the camera
would otherwise roll so the camera's
just following someone down the corner I
have a question about Flat Earth
[Music]
before you do flat Earth yes I think we
should offer Coop do you have a question
for the opportunity to ask a question
Coop please he's our intern uh intern
cool my one question is if aliens are
real how much do you think it'll
actually change anything like if what's
real like if they brought an alien like
you said it'd be great we'd learn more
about biology it would transform but you
back up I'm looking at your ass if we
okay
and maybe it would signal a change in
the human condition that we cannot
foresee or imagine
but we have been challenged by
interestingly similar constructs before
the idea that Earth is not in the center
of the known universe that we have a
complete scientific accounting for the
origin of humans that does not invoke
biblical uh Genesis
um these are these are mind-altering
Revelations if I use a religious word
about our our knowledge of our place in
the universe to find out that we're not
alone would be very cool what would be
disturbing if the alien would clearly
weigh smarter than us and if they wanted
to they can bring others and just make
us their pets that would that would
disturb many people I would suspect now
I have a question last question when you
have to go about uh flat earthers always
say hey how come the planes when they're
flying don't have to adjust to the curve
of the earth when they're flying
straight why do they not have to adjust
to the curve I mean I think I know the
answer but I would like to hear your
answer because it's flat that's why yeah
why don't they have to we're much much
smaller they would have to continue to
adjust to the curvature of the Earth but
Earth is huge compared to an airplane
so the adjustment they make for the
curvature is very small and it just
happens it happens continually I just
don't notice because it's so it's so the
Earth is very large that's what stumps
flat earthers the Earth is so much
larger compared to us it feels like it's
flat and I empathize with that sentiment
but that's why we have the methods and
tools of science to transcend the access
that our five senses have
to objective reality
because your senses suck that's why you
can have books that have optical
illusions oh is the line in the page out
is it longer I don't know simple line
drawings will stump your brain blue
dress right and now we're going to say
let's use our senses to decide what is
objectively real in the world no leave
them at the door invoke scientific
methods and tools that's why science was
invented that's why civilization took
off with the invention of the methods
and tools of science and speaking of
using your senses use your sight and
your eyeballs to read this book to
infinity and beyond it's available right
now just came out the new book by Neil
deGrasse Tyson to infinity and beyond uh
your books are always so great as are
your appearances uh Violent J is uh
headed out uh to continue on the
three-headed monster tour uh he's gonna
be in he was in Brooklyn last night
he'll be in Montreal tonight there's
additional dates through early October I
think I've seen videos with you in it
doing weird things is this is what I'm
remembering usually two of us oh yeah
all right sorry what happened we throw
soda and I got a ninth grade education
okay yeah okay there's a hatchet man
involved I'm gonna find you I'm gonna
find get some more of you I'll bet I see
[__] pieces seriously I like knowing
what's out there I like knowing all the
forces that shape what we call Modern
civilization and you would clearly be
among them that's right ain't no saboo
your mama threw a coffee table that's
right don't forget it we're putting it
down